hello everyone it is august 3rd 2022
and it's actinf guest stream number 25.1
we're here with Brett Andersen
and we'll be hearing about autistic-like
traits and positive schizotype as
diametric specializations of the
predictive mind
there will be first a presentation
followed by a discussion segment so if
you're watching live feel free to add
any comments or questions
and brett thank you again for joining
and
on with the presentation
all right thank you Daniel uh for having
me
so yeah this is a paper that was
published this earlier this month
and uh so
before I get into the paper I should
probably introduce myself just a little
bit so I am an evolutionary psychology
phd student at the university of new
mexico
my research mainly has to do with
something called the diametric model of
autism and psychosis which i'll talk
more about that here in just a minute
so I am not
trained in active inference or
predictive processing I came to this
because I was looking
for a theory that could explain
variation along this autism schizotype
continuum and i'll i'll say what that is
here in just a minute
and I came across uh santa croix or
let's see Sander Van de Cruys and
colleagues 2014 their paper about autism
published in psychological review
and it was through that paper that i
sort of came to write this paper because
uh I realized at some point that that
was the theory I was looking for and
that
uh the opposite configuration of what
they put forward so they said that
autism results from giving an inflexibly
high weight to sensory input and what i
realized through reading that paper and
reading some other stuff around the
topic
was that giving an inflexibly low weight
to sensory input does a really good job
of explaining the other side of that
continuum and so that's what this paper
is about
so i'm putting forward
an explanation for a for a continuum of
individual differences
so uh just an idea of what i'm going to
talk about here so i'm going to talk
about the diametric model of autism and
psychosis what it is what some of the
evidence for it is
how it manifests in non-clinical
populations which is what my research
mainly focuses on and we refer to that
as the autism schizotype continuum
uh and then the hypothesis that I put
forward in this paper which has to do
with explaining variation along this
continuum uh due to trade-offs in
precision weighting due to precision
weighting and and then i'll talk about
some implications for predictive
processing and active reference
so the diametric model
of autism and psychosis was first put
forward by Crespi and Babcock uh Bernie
crest Bernie Crespi and Christopher
Babcock in a 2008 bbs paper
and
it is very simply uh very simply put
just the idea that autism spectrum
conditions and psychosis spectrum
conditions are cognitive and genetic
opposites
before I get into some of the evidence
for it I want to at least address what i
think is the most common objection i
hear it all the time which is that
how can the diametric model be true
given that some people who are diagnosed
with an autism spectrum condition
experience psychosis and vice versa
right so there's there's comorbidity
between these
disorders how can this diametric model
be the case
be true and
i have a whole video about that on my
youtube channel I might put the link in
the comments to this to this youtube
video uh but
basically
the response to this objection is just
to point out that DSM categories are
extremely heterogeneous so within each
DSM category you're going to find
multiple etiologies that may be totally
unrelated to each other in some cases so
for example you could have somebody
diagnosed with an autism spectrum
condition
uh is is diagnosed with that mainly
because for example they have like a
language condition they have maybe a
language delay and that causes a
communicative a communication problem
and then they get the autism diagnosis
and it's not supposed to happen that way
but it definitely does happen that way
and so that would be different from
somebody who has a more classical
presentation with restricted and
repetitive behaviors and so on and so
that person
their their etiology may have nothing
whatsoever to do with the diametric
model so basically given the
heterogeneity of these conditions we
don't expect to have any precise theory
that's going to explain uh every case of
the condition and that includes the
diametric model
so what is some of the evidence for the
i think the best evidence for it is just
to point out all of the diametrically
related uh characteristics on either
side of this what's what's meant to be a
continuum
so
with autism spectrum conditions
there's evidence that paternally
expressed genes promote autism so
we get two copies of every gene we get
one from our mom and one from our dad
there are a subset of genes that are
called imprinted genes and with those
genes you only express one of those
copies so you might express the copy
from you only from your dad
that's a paternally expressed gene
paternally expressed genes when they're
hyper expressed tend to promote autism
and
autism spectrum conditions
we see overgrowth in autism especially
in infancy hypomentalizing which is
reduced attribution of mental states to
other people reduced imagination hyper
systemizing
relative right hemisphere dysfunction
increased cancer rates which is related
to the genomic imprinting issue and we
also see a sex difference where men tend
to be higher in autistic like traits and
they tend to be diagnosed with autism
more often and on the psychosis side of
things we see a lot of opposite
characteristics so we see evidence that
maternally expressed genes promote
psychosis spectrum conditions we see
undergrowth especially in infancy
hypermentalizing which is increased
attribution of mental states to other
people often that that manifest as
paranoia
increased imagination apophenia which is
predisposition to false positives
relative left hemisphere dysfunction
reduced cancer rates at least with
schizophrenia and we also see a sex
difference with positive schizotypes so
women tend to be higher in positive
schizotype
we're talking about psychosis so men
tend to be so the the type of psychosis
that men tend to present with tends to
be
more often degenerative schizophrenia
uh whereas women tend to uh present more
with acute psychosis which seems to have
more of a relation to the diametric
model so
um
now what this paper is focused on is how
the diametric model manifests in
non-clinical population so we we talk
about autistic like traits on one end of
this continuum and positive schizotype
on the other and so the hypothesis put
forward in this paper is not primarily
about dysfunction it's not primarily
about explaining mental condition mental
disorders or mental conditions it's
about explaining a continuum of
individual differences that we all fall
somewhere along and so this is the this
is referred to as the autism
schizotheric continuum
on the autistic side on the uh side
associated with autistic like traits
we see hypomentalizing reduced
imagination
increased systemizing they tend to be
relatively poor at noisy pattern
detection although they're very good at
pattern detection when there's not a lot
of noise in the system
we see this narrow focused attention
style
and people high in autistic like traits
are over represented among engineers and
other technical
professions on the positive schizotype
side we see hypermentalizing increased
imagination reduced systemizing
apophinia and this more broad
distractible attention style and they
tend to be over represented among
artists and other creative professions
and so
the hypothesis that I put forward to try
to explain variation along this
continuum I refer to it as the precision
weighting of sensory input hypothesis
uh as i'm sure everybody listening to
this knows precision weighting underlies
the allocation of attention
so
you can adjust
the precision that you're giving to
sensory input in order to account for
noise in the input
and van der kroys and colleagues in
their 2014 paper published in
psychological review uh this was not the
only so there was a few papers published
around this time that were sort of
talking about this idea theirs was the
first to really put it forward and like
in full detail
so they argued that autism spectrum
disorders are caused by giving an
inflexibly high weight to sensory
prediction errors
and my paper simply extends this
hypothesis i'm arguing that there is a
continuum of individual differences
characterized by people who give a
relatively high weight to sensory input
on one side that's associated with
autism and autistic electrodes
and people who give a relatively low
weight to sensory input on the other
side which is associated with positive
schizotyping
and these differences are going to be
associated with
uh over with with sort of leaning
towards overfitting sensory input which
is what happens in autism
and leaning towards underfitting sensory
input and that under fitting can explain
some of the features of positive
schizotyping and so just to give a
visual demonstration of this
there's a very simplified visual
demonstration but the dots here are
sensory input right and the line is the
model so if you're overfitting if you're
leaning towards giving a high weight to
sensory input
you're going to end up fitting your
model too precisely to the data and that
means that you're going to incorporate
so a lot of that variation in the model
is noise you're going to end up
incorporating noise into your model
the opposite problem that you can have
is instead of giving too much weight to
the sensory input you're giving too much
weight to your hypothesis about the
input so you're kind of imposing your
hypothesis onto the model you're
imposing your prediction onto the input
so in this example on the right hand
side of the screen
the top down prediction is that the data
is linear
and if you give too much weight to that
prediction you can end up imposing a
linear model onto the data
and
something like this I will argue is
going on in positive schizotype and then
there is some optimal balance that
you're going to find that is going to
give you the best chance of finding the
pattern underlying the data importantly
that balance is is never the same or
it's not it's not stable so it depends
on how much noise is in the data depends
on how how much you want to generalize
from the data and so there is no single
optimal solution right there are always
trade-offs associated with this
and so
these are the differences that I am i'm
going to
argue that I can explain with this
hypothesis
so differences along the autism
schizotype continuum these include
bottom-up versus top-down influences on
perception and cognition hypomentalizing
versus hypermentalizing reduced
imagination versus increased imagination
and everything everything on the left
here is associated with the autistic
like traits and then narrow detailed
attention versus broad distractible
attention apophinia which is associated
with positive schizotype systemizing
which is associated with autism and
autistic like traits and then
differences in the propensity for
exploration
so we're going to go through all of
these and show how this hypothesis may
be able to account for them
so
with bottom-up versus top-down
influences on perception uh Crespi and
Dinsdale in a 2019 paper reviewed
evidence for diametric susceptibility to
the rubber hand illusion so most people
probably know what the rubber hand
illusion is got a little visual thing on
the right hand side that shows what it
is so with the rubber hand illusion you
have your real hand hidden by some
screen or something and a rubber hand is
placed in front of you where you think
the real hand is going to go
and
the experimenter will take a feather or
something and they will stroke your real
hand at the same time as they stroke the
rubber hand and that will produce the
illusion that the rubber hand belongs to
you
and oftentimes at the end of the
experiment they'll take a hammer and
slam it down on the rubber hand and
you'll jump and and all that so you
really you really do sort of think that
the hand is yours
uh what Crespi and Dinsdale reviewed
evidence for is that
oh um before I get to that so Jakob
Hohwy I think that's how you say that
say his name uh Jakob Hohwy in his book
suggested that the illusion works
because of the top-down prior belief
that systematically related properties
in this case seeing a hand being stroked
and feeling your own hand being stroked
at the same time are very likely to be
causally related and so what that means
is that
susceptibility to the illusion should be
facilitated by by giving more weight to
your top down prior so a relative
overweighting of top-down priors should
facilitate susceptibility to the
illusion and decreased susceptibility
should be facilitated by giving more
weight to bottom-up sensor input and so
in that case we would expect for autism
and autistic like traits to be associ
associated with reduced susceptibility
and positive schizotype and psychosis to
be associated with more susceptibility
and that is what Crespi and Dinsdale
find so they find that
autism is associated with reduced
susceptibility and vice versa for
positive schizotype and uh
predisposition to psychosis
so
moving on to mentalizing
within the predictive processing
framework uh mentalizing our theory of
mind is thought to result from the use
of relatively abstract or high-level
predictions uh priors to predict other
people's behavior and so
again sort of the same principle as the
last time if that's the case we would
expect an overweighting of bottom-up
input relative to relative to priors
should result in hypomentalizing or
reduced attribution of mental states to
other people and an overweighting of
priors should result in the opposite of
hypermentalizing or giving
an increased attribution of mental
states to other people and of course
that is what we find associated with the
autism schizotype continuum uh this was
one of the things that van der kroys and
colleagues talked about in their 2014
paper but the opposite
positive schizotypal does result in the
opposite
finding
so next up is imagination
uh Andy Clark in a 2013 paper he argued
that we we go into our imagination when
we should when we sufficiently turn down
the weight that we're giving to
proprioceptive sensory input and so when
we do that we are now dealing with our
top down prediction sort of offline
right unmoored from the sensory input
what this should mean is that if you're
giving an inflexibly high weight to
sensory input that should make it more
difficult to turn down that weight
enough to go into your imagination
if you're giving an inflexibly low
weight to sensory input this should mean
that you will find it easier to go into
your imagination and that is we we do
find this difference along the autism
schizotypal continuum so people high in
autistic like traits
uh they have imaginative deficits often
and people high in positive schizotype
they do better on tasks that at least
purportedly measure imagination like
divergent thinking tasks
there's evidence that they spend more
time daydreaming and mind wandering and
of course they're also over represented
among artists and creative professions
so
uh moving on to attention
abu aakl and colleagues in a couple
papers in 2017 and 2018
demonstrated diametric attention styles
for people high and positive
schizotyping and people high in autistic
like traits what they showed
especially in the in the 2018 paper uh
people high in autistic like traits do
better on a task where they had to
ignore salient distractors right so
the task was essentially they had to
focus on something on the screen and
they had to ignore salient distractors
that would pop up in the periphery and
that facilitated them doing better on
the task
on the other hand people high in
positive schizotype
did better on a task that was
facilitated by the opposite by being
distracted by the by the things in the
periphery uh so we see this sort of
focused attention style with autism and
we see this uh more diffuse distractible
attention style with positive schizotype
there is other evidence for this and i
review that in the paper if you want to
look at that
so
the question is how can the PSI
hypothesis account for this I think this
one even though it should you might
think it's the most straightforward one
because precision weighting is about
attention and this is attention
it's actually I think the least
straightforward one
and the reason why
is because
it does seem somewhat intuitive that
if you're
being bombarded
sort of by highly precise sensory
prediction errors which is what we argue
happens in autism uh you might think
that would make you more distractible
and vice versa for positive schizotypes
since they're only paying attention to
relatively large prediction errors that
might make them less distractible
that is that isn't the case but
it'll take a little bit of unpacking to
explain why and i'm going to use an
analogy here we're going to use what i'm
calling the fire department analogy
so you can imagine that you have two
fire departments we'll just call them
fire department a and fire department b
and there are three kinds of fires that
you could have so you could have small
fires medium fires and large fires
and these departments
receive calls about the fires but they
are not told how big the fires are right
so they get a call they're told that
there's a fire at this location but
they're not told whether it's a small
medium or large fire they're just told
that there's a fire
department a
has a policy where they they receive
calls about all kinds of fires right so
they receive calls about small medium
and large fires and department b has a
policy where they only receive calls
about large fires right so they don't
take calls about small and medium fires
i'm arguing that this is basically
equivalent you know within this analogy
to giving a high weight to sensory input
for department a which they take calls
about all fires and as van der kroy's
and colleagues pointed out in their 2014
paper when you're giving a high weight
to sensory input you're treating all of
these sensory prediction errors as if
they're all important
the problem with that of course is that
not all sensory prediction errors are
actually important
department b who only receives calls
about large fires this is equivalent to
giving a low weight to sensory input
so which strategy works better that
depends on the context so if there are
more fires than you can put out at a
given time right if the whole city
catches fire at once department b works
better because in that case you actually
don't want to pay attention to the small
fires where you only want to pay
attention to the large fires you want to
ignore the details uh if there's not
that many fires at a time you don't want
to ignore small fires right you want to
pay attention to the small fires so
department a works better in that
context
so
now imagine that these two departments
are in the midst of putting out a
particularly large and important fire
they receive a call about a new fire and
the question here is what should they do
in relation to this call department a
should maintain focus on the current
fire that's because when they receive a
call they don't know whether it's small
medium or large it's more likely to be
small or medium
so they should ignore the call maintain
focus on their current task
department b should be more willing to
allocate resources to the new fire right
they know that it's a large fire because
they only receive calls about large
fires so they should be more willing to
redirect their attentional resources
okay this is my argument for why we see
this
uh attentional difference along the
autism schizotypal continuum uh people
high and autistic like traits have
learned that the peripheral prediction
errors are very likely to be unimportant
and that they should focus on the task
at hand that learning probably happens
unconsciously
uh people behind positive schizotype
have learned the opposite right
if they're if they receive a prediction
error on the periphery they've learned
to assume that it's important right
because they only pay attention to
important prediction areas so
uh so anyways this this analogy is what
i'm using to explain this attentional
difference along the autism schizotype
continuum
uh so moving on to systemizing
so people high in autistic like traits
and people with with an autism spectrum
condition are often very skilled at
learning about
uh rules-based systems so this would be
something like a computer programming
language most of mathematics falls under
this category uh they tend to be very
good at these things
and
if you'll remember you know overfitting
results from incorporating noise into
into your predictive model
the thing about a rules-based system is
that there is no noise in that system if
it's if it's truly rules-based then when
you put in a certain input you get the
same output every time it can be an
extremely complex these can be extremely
complex rules uh like there are with
computer programming languages but
they're extremely precise
and so that highly precise cognitive
perceptual style that comes with giving
a high weight to sensory input is going
to facilitate the systemizing ability
with with autism and autistic like
traits
so for a visual demonstration of this
you can have this complex pattern
and there's no noise in the pattern
right it might be highly complex but
there's no noise
if you're giving a high weight to
sensory input you can fit your model as
precisely as you want to this pattern
and you're not going to run into the
problem of overfitting because there is
no noise to be incorporated in the model
people high in positive schizotyping on
the other hand may attempt to impose a
simplifying assumption onto the model
right they may attempt to impose
simplifying assumptions onto this
complex but non-noisy input
and that will lead them to not be as
good at systemizing
and that is what we find
so
looking at noisy patterns now so people
with autism spectrum conditions are
relatively poor at picking up on noisy
patterns
i was not able to get to this in the
paper because I didn't have room but it
is something that I would have included
if I had room uh we reviewed the
evidence for this in an upcoming paper
with myself john vervicky and mark
miller
so if you're giving a high weight to
sensory input
it's going to make it more difficult to
pick up on patterns that were that are
embedded in noise
and there is no evidence that people
high in positive schizotype have issues
with noisy patterns so apophinia has a
different thing we'll talk about the
next but but there is evidence for this
with autistic like traits and ASD.
we can understand why that's the case
for the same reason so
if you have this noisy data and you're
trying to fit your model very precisely
to that noisy data you are not going to
pick up on the underlying pattern right
you're going to miss out on the
underlying pattern you're going to
over fit your model to this data
so people high in positive schizotypy
really ought to be better at picking up
on these kinds of noisy patterns because
they're not going to they're not going
to miss out on the big picture by paying
too much attention to the details is
essentially what would happen there
so apophinia is the next one so
apophinia is when you perceive patterns
and pure noise right and this is thought
to be a core feature of positive
schizotype
uh so for example people high in
positive schizotypal are more likely to
hear messages if they're if you listen
to audio that's pure noise they're more
likely to say that they heard a voice in
the noise or something like that
and giving a low weight to sensory input
means that they will often impose their
top down assumptions onto onto pure
noise
there's no evidence that people high in
autistic like traits have issues with
apophenia
and so again this is just a visual
demonstration of this
um with autistic like traits when
they're presented with pure noise again
they're not going to see any pattern in
that right they're just going to see
randomness people high in positive
schizotype
may again they may attempt to impose a
pattern onto this data
because they're giving more weight to
the top down to the top down assumption
and less weight to the bottom up input
so I think this is the last one I might
finish a little early
exploitation exploration so we do see uh
evidence
okay so yeah so deciding whether to
exploit current opportunities or search
for new ones direct exploration is a
fundamental trade-off that faces all
organisms
and there is evidence that people high
and positive schizotype are more
exploratory than people high in autistic
like traits so for example they are
higher in the personality traits of
openness
and extraversion uh Colin deYoung and
some of
some of his colleagues have argued that
those two traits form a higher order
trait called plasticity and the young
has argued that that plasticity
represents the general tendency towards
exploration so that's uh some evidence
uh for differences in exploratory
tendency we also see differences in
sensation seeking associated with this
so sensation seeking has also been
argued to be an indicator of exploratory
tendency
so
Kiverstein and colleagues and 2019 paper
said this
they they said that a large but
resolvable error signal informs the
agent that the environment offers the
opportunity or offers the opportunity to
resolve uncertainty
that opportunity to resolve uncertainty
makes exploration an attractive option
the issue is
so if you're if you're giving an
inflexibly high weight to sensory input
what that means is that you're not
seeing large differences between the
prediction errors that are that you're
receiving
giving a low weight to sensory input
means that people high in positive
schizotyping only tend to pay attention
to large prediction errors and these
large prediction errors are more likely
to incentivize exploration they
represent a greater potential
information game
information gain and so people high in
high and autistic like traits
we see that autism is associated with
restricted and repetitive behaviors and
relatively narrow interests
uh and that me and that's a reflection
of this reduced exploration
yeah so like I said before giving a high
weight to sensory input means that most
prediction errors are going to be
treated as relatively equal and in
importance and as van der kroys and
colleagues pointed out in the 2014 paper
if each prediction error is as important
as the next it is more difficult to
estimate
where predictive process can be made and
therefore
exploration is not as enticing
this comes with a benefit however
because the the decreased exploration
that's associated with autistic
literates
is also why they tend to be more
competent specialists they tend to
specialize on one highly particular
domain
and sort of drill deep into one thing
instead of spreading out their options
over many things
they are less likely to be distracted by
emergent opportunities
so
what are some of the implications of
this hypothesis
uh so like I said van der kroys and
colleagues their 2014 theory about
autism
should not be seen as being just a
theory about autism but rather as a
basis for a theory about individual
differences in general
because in addition to people who give
an inflexibly high weight to sensory
input
i've argued here that there are people
who also given inflexibly low weight to
sensory prediction errors and those are
people high in positive schizotyping
and this uh just as a reminder this
should not be thought of in terms of
dysfunction
it is a continuum of individual
differences that we all fall somewhere
along right so this is just a
a continuum that that will occur in
non-clinical populations as well
and this paper was an initial attempt to
sketch the evidence and implications of
this idea
there is still room for an empirical
research program to test and extend this
this idea and that's what i'm going to
do with the rest of my phd most likely
and theoretical work on its implications
so I am an evolutionary psychologist so
i should talk a little bit about some
evolutionary implications
the autism schizotypal continuum is a
highly heritable source of individual
differences we know that autism and
schizophrenia for example are about
have a heritability of about 0.8 so
they're very heritable
this means that they're going to be
highly responsive to selection pressures
and if this hypothesis that put forward
here is correct my contention is that
this continuum is very likely equivalent
or at least analogous to
specialist generalist continuums
elsewhere in biology and
that is because the the precise
perceptual style and autism is going to
facilitate specializing for highly
particular domains we do see this with
autism they tend to have relatively
narrow interests but that allows them to
be
to become very specialized in some some
particular domain
the imprecise perceptual style with
positive schizotype is going to
facilitate picking up on these more
noisy patterns and noisy patterns tend
to be more generalizable they tend to
generalize across context a little bit
better
so
there are models from theoretical
biology that have been used to
understand how specialist generalist
continuums like this can evolve
and basically the you know if I was
going to extract a general principle
from these models uh what they what they
tend to argue is that if you have
periods of relative stability punctuated
occasionally by periods of upheaval so
if you have fluctuating selection
pressures this can maintain a heritable
continuum of individuals individual
differences like this one
and there is evidence that this was the
environment that characterized human
beings before the advent of agriculture
so before the advent of agriculture
there was a lot more fluctuations in the
climate things were changing a lot more
often
so we could see the evolution of a
continuum of individual differences or
at least the maintenance of a continuum
like this one
so that is the end
and thank you to Daniel thank you to the
active inference institute for letting
me share my work
and that is it
thanks a lot you can unshare and we'll
talk a little bit more about this in our
store
all right
well to those who are watching along
live
please feel free to add any questions in
and if they're relevant we'll go with
them
well
a lot there
and
i wrote down
a bunch of questions
so
to enter the maze at just one point
here we have two axes
about the extent of the two traits that
you're focusing on
and the diametric model in my
understanding summarizes a manifold and
says that there's correlation across
these two dimensions
so I wondered what is that state space
are these like the big two
or what exactly
else might be in this broader space of
traits
yeah it's a really good question and
uh the thing is you know if we're
looking at something like
the big five right so this is how we
normally think about individual
differences we think about them in terms
of the big five as a psychologist
the thing about the big five is that it
my argument would be that it doesn't
carve nature at its joints right it's
this very top-down way of understanding
individual differences
and it doesn't it's it's completely
neutral about mechanism
with this with the autism schizotype
continuum
we're coming at things from the opposite
direction right so it's a bottom-up uh
way of thinking about individual
differences and
at least if this hypothesis is correct
we have a mechanism right if this does
explain the things I think it explains
in it we have a mechanism to explain it
now clearly
and you know if if it is just precision
weighting
given the importance of precision
weighting within the predictive
processing framework we would expect
this to be a pretty important uh source
of individual differences however there
are clearly many other sources of
individual differences that are going to
interact with this in
uh unpredictable ways so for example you
know you're going to have you're going
to have
things that are that are mediated for
example by
blood testosterone levels right there
are clearly individual differences
mediated by
testosterone levels I don't think this
has much to do with that so how does
that interact with this how do you know
uh differences in something like
agreeableness which I don't think has
much to do with this you know how do
these things interact it's it's a big
question um my advisor and I are working
on a scale to measure this stuff so that
we can start unpacking some of those
interactions and trying to figure some
of that out but I would say that we're
just at the very beginning of that of
that process so
you know sort of conclude on your quest
on your question
um
we don't really know I think that this
is a large source of individual
differences but
in terms of how much of the variation
and something like the big five trait of
openness for example clearly this has
something to do with variation and
openness how much does it account for
we also know that intelligence accounts
for some of that variation how much does
intelligence account for compared to
this these are all open questions that
that we're still
we still haven't answered yet
awesome thank you
sure
when I was seeing the
side-by-side traits I was really struck
by the mention of cancer
and
i am not an expert however these
conditions in their clinical forms and
potentially in their subclinical
variances
are associated with other organ systems
like digestive system and skin and
immunity and so on
so I was just curious about what
was
the cancer empirical finding and how did
this relate to
multi-tissue multi-system effects and
maybe even embodied cognition
yeah yeah so it is the case that autism
conditions are associated with an
increased cancer rate uh with psychosis
the evidence is a little bit more mixed
so it is uh
at least at the time that that Crespi
and babcock wrote their paper
there was good evidence that
schizophrenia is associated with reduced
cancer rates i've looked at some of the
evidence more recently with
schizophrenia I think that that that
finding is still solid with bipolar
disorder which is another psychosis
spectrum condition uh the findings are
definitely more mixed either way the the
fact that schizophrenia is associated
with reduced cancer is a very strange
finding uh and the reason you know main
reason why is because schizophrenia is
pretty much associated with everything
negative you can think of I mean the
fact that it's it's associated with
reduced cancer rates
is strange just in light of that fact
um
athena activists wrote a book
about cancer in 2018 I wish I could
remember the name of that book
but
in that book she talked about so she
didn't talk about it in terms of autism
and psychosis but she talked about it in
terms of imprinted genes so I i said
that autism is associated with
paternally expressed genes and psychosis
is associated with maternally expressed
genes
um
with imprinted genes
what happens is that the genes that are
that come from your dad they promote
your dad's genetic interests now the
thing about human beings is that we do
not have complete paternity certainty
meaning
that it's not always you don't always
know if you're a man you don't always
know that the kids are yours right uh as
a mother you know that all the kids are
yours and you don't always know as a man
they're gonna have kids with the same
with the same woman so the paternally
expressed genes have an interest in
promoting growth they have an interest
in taking as much of the mother's
resources as they can
and that is what they do and because
they promote growth if they're hyper
expressed they will also end up
promoting cancer because cancer is
something that uh that results from too
much of you know the hormones that
promote growth it can result from that
on the other side with psychosis
because it's associated with maternally
expressed genes
so as I said it's associated with
undergrowth and infancy it's also
associated with reduced suckling so
kids who grow grow up to have
schizophrenia they don't suckle as much
they don't take as much of their
mother's milk
they also um there's evidence that they
also just tend to be more calm as
children
and this is the the idea of the theory
here is that this is because
they are promoting their mother's
interests right they have more they're
they're expressing their mother's genes
more and that promotes their the things
that are interest that are in the
interest of the mother's genetic
interests so that would be reduced
growth reduce suckling being an easier
baby they take care of and so on uh so
that's the that's the the most um i
think that's the most prominent
explanation for why we see this cancer
difference
that answers the question
very interesting and
staying with that topic of
intergenerational imprinting
that part was interesting to me as an
insect biologist because
parental imprinting is often used to be
exploring differences in phenotype
across nest mates within a colony
so
is this a key
uh
domain of imprinting are imprinting
effects
widespread outside of this
uh diametric model and what does this
imprinting mechanism tell us about
intergenerational epigenetic effects
more broadly
yeah so
in terms of the effect of imprinting so
i think that they're I i'm confident
that imprinting plays a role
in variation in this continuum but how
much of a role I think is very much up
in the air I don't think that we have a
good idea of
how many genes are actually imprinted uh
the the number of genes that are said to
be imprinted is about 200.
both my advisor and I have expressed our
doubts about this we think that it's
probably more widespread than that and
there are difficulties in picking up on
something so you could have partial
imprinting for example uh that it would
be more difficult to pick up on
uh but yeah so
in terms of how this
i I think it's pretty important uh
christopher badcock who was one of the
the authors on the on the first paper
he's written a couple of books about
this he's made the case that it's very
important
um I published a paper
a couple years ago
showing that people high in positive
schizotype they tend to
migrate more often or you know what i
what we actually showed is that they
have more intentions to migrate we've
argued that that would lead to more
migration but they at least say that
they they are more likely to or they
they want to move to other locations
more now what you see in the animal
literature
is that dispersal is often a mechanism
to reduce competition among
among family members essentially
you don't want to be competing with all
of your siblings
maybe that has something to do with it
here it's a little different with humans
because we're so cooperative but if we
were being consistent with the animal
literature that would be consistent with
the animal literature on that on that
kind of stuff
um
yeah there's there's some very strange
findings associated with this too
i feel like are very controversial but
i'll mention them anyways um
so there was a book written so there was
a paper and I i'm putting forward this
stuff as very speculative so I want to
be clear about that
these are speculative things but there's
a paper
written a couple years ago about
imprinting making the case
that paternally expressed genes in
humans
will be associated with more war-like
behaviors
so and this is because
humans are thought to
was the word be more patrilocal so it is
the the women who tend to disperse more
often which means that you're the the
people who are in your group are more
likely to be your male relatives
and
they make an argument that that will
lead to an increased uh
group-like behavior in all this
now
a couple of findings that are associated
with that which which are strange at
least and that they might be associated
with that there was a book published a
couple years ago called the engineers of
jihad and
what they what they pointed out in that
book is that
people in engineering and technical
professions are massively over
represented among radical islamists and
they're massively overrepresented among
radical right-wingers which is a little
surprising to me but the the data is
very clear on that
and I can't think of more
war-like ideologies than those two you
know uh if we're gonna be consistent
with that with that theory now again i
regard that as speculative but it's it's
an interesting finding nonetheless we
also see that people in the
humanities uh who tend to be higher in
positive schizotypes so they are the
sort of artsy types they tend to be so
people in the humanities are definitely
more
left-wing than other people
and that's associated with ideologies
that are sort of against war more often
uh so
so it's kind of an interesting finding
um I would like to explore it more but i
i don't know
i would say it's definitely speculative
anyways there's a lot of interesting
implications of this that again have yet
to be explored
it's one of those experiments where you
want a small sample size
pretty rare for biology
um
a few more areas I think that would be
awesome to explore
so
mixing it up a little bit
how does what you're sharing and
learning
help us think about how to be respectful
in our facilitation and communication in
neurodiverse settings
yeah so I think it's important to
recognize that
uh
there are strengths and weaknesses
associated with the with the sides of
the continuum so
um
you know I i think that we often
we often tend to think that the the
people who think very differently than
us and it's easy to come you know it's
easy to sort of tell if somebody uh has
a very different thinking style than you
um
i think that it's it's very easy to sort
of think that that other thinking style
is is less useful in whatever way
um I think it's important to understand
that
you know really the implication of this
is that we're we're all good
um and of course there you know there's
an iq thing as well that plays into this
but we're all we're all
going to be relatively better or worse
at picking up on different kinds of
patterns
uh so people on that autistic side
they're very good at picking up on these
precise patterns right that are you know
it's associated with engineering
computer programming physics and
mathematics and the more noisy patterns
and the more
not only noisy patterns but what's the
word
[Music]
unstructured problems right so
unstructured problems uh that require
these sort of ins so there is evidence
that people high in positive schizotype
are better at solving insect problems
for example like the nine dot problem if
anybody is familiar with that
um and so that's a that's an important
difference and yeah I mean we're you
know
um I think that understanding this can
help people to be a little more
empathetic towards people who think
differently than them yeah
and also seeing like
cognitive diversity amongst the nest
mates
in the context of the decision that the
colony has to make
can be harnessed and so that's very
useful and definitely there's a
long supply chain and last mile to
respecting people in different specific
contexts but definitely this helps link
up a lot of the general themes like you
mentioned explore exploit generalist
specialist
these are broader trends in biology and
in statistics and machine learning and
then
the dance and the art and the science
potentially is about
bringing to bear
these empirically informed and
analytically derived in some situations
frameworks and then meeting
with
the situatedness
of someone in their own n equals one
trajectory to really like
make it work
in that one situation
yeah
okay um
there's a a sequence of questions I have
on attention but
first in the very beginning you
mentioned um
finding active inference and predictive
processing framework
and
kind of latching onto that and using
that to continue building your research
direction so
what
was it
from a
framework feature perspective
that you felt was going to be providing
a better explanation or prediction
just how do you
sense make amidst all of these decades
and decades of bayesian brain predictive
processing and coding active inference
all these different threads in cognitive
sciences and neuroscience
what makes you
go the way that you're going with your
phd
yeah I mean well you know I think i've
read almost every theory of autism that
there is you know like in terms of
cognitive theories I mean obscure
dissertations and all this stuff
um
the reason I i came to this predictive
processing understanding is just because
it's the one that explains
so of course I was coming at this from
the perspective of the diametric model
right and this is the only thing that i
found that that adequately to my mind
explains both sides of this continuum
uh other theories of autism you know
maybe they maybe they work for
explaining some features of autism but i
needed something that worked for both
right and this was this was what worked
for both and so when i
uh when I realized that and I actually i
sort of had that revelation while I was
reading Andy Clark's book really uh
surfing uncertainty um when I realized
that I i realized that you know I i
should
learn more about this framework and so i
sort of started consuming literature on
predictive processing very uh
obsessively
and
at this point I think it's uh so another
project I have you know I would like to
work on
is integrating some of the insights from
evolutionary psychology with with
predictive processing I think that's an
integration that could be really
interesting
um
but yeah that was basically it it's just
that this uh that explanation the van
der kroys and colleagues in their 2014
paper you know the explanation they put
forward for autism not only explained
autism but the opposite explained the
other side for me and so that's kind of
why I sort of latched on to this
this framework
and do you think following in that that
there are unique explanations or unique
experimental designs that would help us
reduce our uncertainty about some of
these contending theories
yeah yeah I mean for the predictive
processing uh
theory you know we need more experiments
on attention right because this is the
most I think this is sort of the most
straight well you know straightforward
but it's it's the most obvious
implication right if
these are really differences in
precision weighting we should be able to
precisely uh look at differences in
attention along this continuum and
it's not always clear
you know I i've read uh you know quite a
bit of the experimental work on autism
in relation to this there's been a lot
of it it's not always clear
what the predictions actually are right
some sometimes um yeah sometimes the
predictions are not straightforward
you know this this certainly from a
retroactive perspective I think it
explains all this stuff really well uh
in terms of predicting new stuff right
it's it gets more complicated it just
does you know um and
so one of the things that we're going to
do um for my phd is we're definitely
going to look at the scope of attention
so
it is the case that like people high in
the in the trade of openness to
experience uh they have a wider scope of
attention right and we think this should
be associated with positive schizotype
and there's good evidence that people
with autism have a narrower scope of
attention it's been called tunnel vision
they've called it tunnel vision uh we
want to demonstrate this in non-clinical
populations and uh you know using the
scale that we're making we want to
demonstrate this and so you know that's
one direction that we're going with this
um
yeah i'll stop there I think that's all
i have to say
well awesome it leads to a few attention
related questions that'll be great to
dive into but but one reflection there
is you described it as being able to
retroaddictively connect a lot of dots
through the usage of predictive
frameworks
however
that is
like one of those sides in the
discussion today
are we looking to um or which side are
we looking to err on in that regression
example was provided do we want the wavy
line where the next batch of 10 points
the wavy line is probably going to be
totally off base because the initial
wavy line was overfit
or would we be okay with getting
directional correctness
but very little explanatory power like a
high residual per point and the the
optimum that science as this distributed
system
would be
kind of navigating and weaving around
that path of least action in that space
would be the bayes optimal
regression model which is actually what
is described by the bayesian information
criterion or the AIC its relative and
those are statistical criteria
that balance
exactly that trade-off between a highly
parameterized model that explains all
the variants and then an under
parameterized model too few parameters
that explains maybe even
a good chunk of the variation but then
ultimately leaves a lot on the table
when there's still like a a lot of um
value to be gained by adding some more
parameters so I was just seeing like
that kind of bayesian information
approach and then that's like the sweet
spot
but everybody moment to moment and year
to year and life to life it's like a
swarm weaving in that valley
right and that is what constitutes part
of our
species level neurodiversity
well you know I mean it's a good thing
we have a lot of scientists working on
this problem right so we can especially
with autism you know so we can kind of
go
uh separate ways and meet in the middle
a little bit you know we can kind of
explore different different paths
um yeah yeah go ahead
let's talk a little bit about attention
sure it's definitely a core term in
active inference and it's um
really one of the the tenants even
though in reward-centric paradigms
attention has been used like in neural
networks that have attention and so it's
interesting to see how even in a reward
first paradigm still attentional
features are brought in whereas active
inference and predictive processing have
a principled and analytically derived
approach to attention so
what is attention and what are the uh in
a william james fashion what are the
varieties of the attention experience
yeah that's a tough question uh I mean i
i've seen arguments you know within i
think first in uh first and wrote a
paper a couple years back arguing that
there are these two
uh different kinds of attention within
within this framework right so there's
like salience and then there is uh i
forget what he called the other one but
i'm not so sure that these are not
really uh the same thing um
you know what what it is to to pay
attention to something my understanding
within this framework is to treat
you treat the input as if it's highly
precise right you're treating it as if
it's highly precise in a bayesian sense
that means that you're treating it as if
it's important
it means it's having a large effect on
updating your model
and that includes you know because this
is a hierarchical thing that also
includes stuff that's generated by the
the internal model right so you can give
a high weight to you know a predict you
know a prediction that's generated from
your internal model so you're paying
attention uh to what's going on inside
of your own sort of internal model as
well
uh as far as the varieties of attention
yeah I mean I i don't think I have a
good answer to that uh I don't I don't
know
probably uh but that's but that's how i
would define attention anyways uh with
this within this model
well it seems like a really interesting
direction to
see what kind of formalisms and models
could underlie those um very
gestalt capturing senses of attention
like diffuse and laser and narrow but
those are like spotlight metaphors but
then
where's the spotlight in the prediction
and so it kind of crosses domains and so
there's a lot of interesting um
things there and yes what you said about
uh attention being paid or salience in a
bayesian statistical framework is
exactly that like if there was a prior
about the temperature and no attention
was being paid to incoming thermometer
readings then
that prior would just play out whether
it was a flat or whether it was expected
to change from a top down hierarchical
model whereas if a lot of attention were
being paid to the thermometer readings
in the extreme
you just flip your best prediction to
whatever the thermometer said less last
and so then thinking back to those
regressions that you showed
they could be understood as in in a
static sense
as being like what is the relationship
between
the person's height and how friendly
they are to me
and then that could be like sort of an
all at once static regression about
features of the world or like when it's
raining what is the temperature like so
just sort of across different instances
regression that helps capture the
direction and magnitude and reliability
of some causal outcomes but it's also
interesting to think about that x-axis
as time
and the y-axis is tracking again like
temperature or some other thing in the
world
and there's like the high attention
whiplash with the noisy measurements and
it's like things are very volatile
but they're being fit well
but it's just feels like things are
volatile and then the other extreme
would be just that
straight regression line
where
things are simple
however there's a lot of variability and
that actually also plays into certain
bayesian work on for example like
narrative
and what is called conspiracy theory
thinking
simple
that's the simple regression line that's
narrative and then it's like well then
why is it why is
this why are these five examples in
front of us not the case if that's
totally the way things are in the world
that a is associated with b but here's
five a and it's not associated with b
it's like right well there's error to
explain there's residual but that
doesn't dissuade me from believing that
there is this relationship in the world
that's true
yeah it's interesting uh you know like
the conspiratorial thinking is
associated with positive schizotyping
empirically which is what you would
expect right you know it's a very simple
explanation it explains a lot uh but
it's you know it's a little bit unmoored
from the actual data something like that
it can tolerate high variance
between the prediction and the
observation
and that can be accommodated in a
framework where more attention is being
paid to the narrative prior so the
posterior is not updating that much
seeing a hundred examples of something
happening doesn't really update my
likelihood on what I think is gonna
happen next
um yeah
[Music]
it was it's often the case that you know
with like conspiracy conspiratorial
thinking evidence against the conspiracy
is taken as evidence for the conspiracy
because it's just evidence that they're
really really good at hiding it right
like uh you know like no evidence that
this is going on is actually evidence of
just how good they are at hiding it you
know so you can incorporate almost any
data into those kinds of models right
it's an extremely
uh yeah it's an extremely top-down
biased way of thinking about the world
and I think that's why it's associated
with positive schizotypes
and
it leads to one attention related
question which is
how do we
train our attention or how do we shape
our attention
[Music]
to be who we want to be
well I i think I have two answers to
that question
uh the first one is
meditation I think can help but
also
you know I i've had
issues with with my own attention and
one of the things that made me better at
paying attention to things that I may
not have wanted to pay attention to but
that I really
that I really need to is just having
clear goals right it like gets your like
if you have clear written goals it gets
your dopaminergic system on on your side
right so instead of uh you know so you
get that little that little reward every
time you
do your physics homework or whatever
which you may not want to pay attention
to
but if you're getting rewarded for it
because
you know you have a clear goal that
you're moving towards it makes it easier
to pay attention another thing I would
say
so
in in
i think that's really
it's under-appreciated how much our
attention is related to our values
you know when we value something it
directs our attention towards relevant
towards relation towards things that are
relevant to the goal and so having clear
goals is really important the other
thing I would say
is
instead of you know instead of talking
about changing uh or improving our
attention is to put yourself
into situations that are good for for
your kind of attention style so you know
i'm somebody who
is not on the autistic side of that
continuum
i would never have been an engineer
okay or a physicist or anything like
that you know it's not my thing
um I had to put myself in a situation
where I could use my intellectual
ability the intellectual abilities that
i have I love these big picture things i
love seeing all the dots between all
these disparate things you know that's
what that's what I do
i had to find a way to put myself in a
position where I could use that
um so some of it is is is finding a way
to get yourself in the right context
that allows you to use your own
attention style in the right way so
it's not all about you know partly it's
changing yourself but also partly it's
changing uh the environment that you're
in so that you can you can be who you
are to some degree
and that's definitely echoed
in the ways that an active inference
entity can reduce its variational or
expected free energy which is it can
update its generative model it can
change its mind or it can engage in
action it can change the world
and I feel like that
dialectic
you know yesterday I tried to change the
world today I tried to change myself and
the way that we wouldn't want our
actions to be
malappropriated in the world or to be
believing something falsely like that
there isn't influence of our actions in
the world but also it can be extreme and
unhelpful when people have
far-ranging beliefs about their own
role and so like
social cognition and how that gets
mediated
with attention and shared attention
thinking through other minds and joint
attention general synchrony a lot of
these active inference
ideas are really in a stage where
some of the continents in the map have
been laid out
and there's a lot of exploration
to go fractal exploration to go
to move from
[Music]
framing different things as like a
deficit of reward to a perturbation
of precision
which also navigates the balance with
pathology
because we can say that
bayes optimal cognition is occurring
given the priors and the attention
if this is the prior and here's how much
or this type of attention that's being
paid
that's not a irrational or an even
necessarily an incorrect it might be an
outcome that isn't valued highly under
some social criterion or another but
then again that's that imperative to ask
like what could be different in the
person's developmental trajectory and
their niche which includes their social
niche so
it is just opening up the discussion
around these topics so it's a good time
to be starting your phd in it
yeah yeah definitely yeah with the with
the psychopathology I mean I really love
this you know the the
uh this framework for thinking about
psychopathology because there is that
right like a lot of times what we label
as psychopathology is actually you're
you're working just the way you're
supposed to
um but I do think that there are there
are times where we get caught in like
these feedback loops right we get caught
in these in these sort of uh
mark miller has some good papers about
this in relation to addiction and things
like that you know we get caught in this
uh you know what what they refer to as
reciprocal narrowing
and
it's like we're reducing prediction
error in a local
aspect but we're ignoring all of the all
of the other areas in which we could be
reducing prediction error so like if
you're addicted to a drug
of some kind if it's like a dopaminergic
uh substance it's going to tell you that
like you're doing great right you're
reducing prediction error you know uh
you know in an awesome way but uh
everywhere around you you know it's just
chaos right um so anyways so yeah i
think this is a really cool framework
for thinking about uh psychopathology in
general
and bring it into that extended
context
if
one cell were growing at the expense of
others if it were having high fitness
that's the kind of evolutionary lens
if it were doing uh if it were modifying
the signaling environment so it was
getting exactly the hormone levels it
expected
even if those were potentially within a
healthy range
that might have deleterious consequences
at the group
fitness or free energy minimization or
reward perspective and so we see kind of
this braiding
when things are working
then
they can be analyzed with
fitness reward precision and when things
fail additionally we kind of see all of
those different framings
coalesce again
and I think the interesting and
informative space
will be to understand
where those frameworks differ not just
to justify or explore scientific
hypotheses but truly to be in that gray
zone and in that situation where it does
matter how we act and whether we're
justifying our actions with this or that
flavor of evolution or reward or
precision type thinking
yeah
yeah it's it's uh yeah and it's it's
exciting to sort of be at the beginning
of this kind of stuff I mean I think
we're really just getting started
um in terms of you know understanding
individual differences from a predictive
processing perspective and
psychopathology um
you know like we're we're working on
some stuff about psychosis too um
and you know how
positive schizotype uh sort of the the
sort of next step in this in this at
least in the theoretical part of this
one of the implications of the
hypothesis I talked about in this paper
so with autism and van der kroys and
colleagues talked about this in their
2014 paper prediction matching should
take place at relatively low levels of
the processing hierarchy right so like
more the more concrete levels of the
processing hierarchy uh for people with
autism and that is sort of what we find
it's a very detail-oriented style
but with positive schizotype you should
see the opposite of prediction errors
traveling farther up the hierarchy and
what we think is happening in psychosis
is basically like those prediction
errors travel up to those
at higher levels of the hierarchy like
those are the those are the priors
upon which many other priors depend and
so if you disrupt those priors right you
lose precision not only on those but on
everything that they're dependent on and
if that happens very suddenly you can
get a massive increase in entropy and a
massive increase in in behavioral and
psychological entropy and kind of think
that's what psychosis is um
it's not entirely original to that idea
but it just sort of talks about how it
develops right because if we know that
people who give a low weight to sensory
input are
are susceptible to it that tells us why
they're susceptible right because those
prediction errors are going to go up to
those more high level priors if that
makes sense
is there anything else you want to add
talk about ask
uh
i think i'm good man I really appreciate
the opportunity to share my work and and
have this conversation
really good
excellent best of luck with your
continued research and education
all right thank you Daniel see you later
bye
you